[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah I will to talk today about my
thoughts of what is the weakest link in
our trust chain in the web platform this
is regarding we will not see any code of
JavaScript or anything else it's more
affordable and it brought me to some
insights which we will see later so the
first question I asked to myself was in
why we trust in our keys we use for
doors and other things so and over these
I'm continued and saying okay there
might be other locks which we are also
trust in next so so they are quite a lot
of other other locks coming up so we
have these thing which is a broken a bad
lock in Firefox which shows like that
another one next to the green lock in
Firefox it looks like that another time
next we have a chrome hopefully a chrome
come on huh please what's that so we
have a chrome lock and we oh I have to
run
[Laughter]
no running broken locks last words
trustworthy Thanks
and yeah that's that's one of my
question I took it's this more - is this
less stressful
it just says okay a connection is not
secure what it doesn't mean
basically it means nothing and and then
are also other people thinking about
these you can't read that it says
basically your information is traveling
the internet and it could be and that's
very important thing it could be that
this is not very secure or safe let's
just say to me okay there are some
concerns possible the nice thing is or
what I also discovered the other browser
vendors never have mentioned such a
thing it's only in Firefox yeah what's
happened that was the next question I
asked to myself what happens to your
trust when you know what that there are
copies of your key out basically it
means you come home and your your space
is empty and nothing is broken of course
that could happen if somebody else has a
key you can open it and kick and steal
whatever if you want and or put new
stuff in it's also possible but
generally in that case we have a problem
with trusting in our locks and keys
that's what's happening if we know that
there are some copies of our keys out
and to gain back access the only
solution we have we can exchange the
lock and the key and hope so and out of
this there was a new question coming up
and I have a lot of questions could we
detect copies
is there any way how we are able to
detect that our keys are copied and in
the physical world
oops ah but in the physical world this
is difficult but the important thing is
to know that in the physical world no
exactly same objects exist anymore so
it's not possible to replicate to 100%
equal then in physical world it's it's
too complicated and there's a lot of
things which says okay I I have no there
are signatures like the signatures from
off bollards which are fired through a
specific gun or you cannot say is a
little bit different there is no perfect
crime in physical world so that every
every time in evidence which says okay
that's a copy that is whatever it makes
it visible that it doesn't work out in
digital it's a complete different story
and in digital copying of data generates
hundred percent 100% perfect objects
which are absolutely identical to the
original or object and that that causes
that we are asking ask a question our
physical object a digital object copied
or not copied is their original no they
opposed copy and there's also some other
constraints were coming into place if
you try to replicate one half thousand
keys it's a hard work to do it's pretty
pretty complex complex in digital it's
basically impossible to distinguish
between the original and the copied
thing so that's very very important for
me it was very important understanding
to get get the knowledge that everything
in digital is the perfect copy and this
is a very common scenario of course I'm
on the left now I'm this
the guy behind with the green lock I'm
very happy and on the other side that
server server guy and he has his own
private key and in this scenario we have
within the first place we did not see
any copies there is no copy of the
private key information they're just
handing out of data we are seeing that
the transport if you use TLS we see that
the transferred integrity is still in
place and we know that there might be
not a third party which can read this
they can read the data which we are
transferring so it's okay but what
happens if we have a third party coming
into this session so and you up the wax
what happens if a third party is coming
into into this session and the nice
thing on on in that case is and the
right one so the server guy hands out
his key to these guy in the middle and
for us that means everything stays green
we still see the green rock but there's
another person who is also able to yeah
modify the data we are transferring and
so on Sun that is that's why I'm called
it the perfect man in the middle
impersonation which based on where that
we are having a loose of the key between
two partners um and in digital universe
it's basically impossible to identify
that this scenario we saw before is
happened of course we have no proof we
have known best nothing different from
the outside to gain any evidence that
there is a copy created of the key and
the next question is what's about the
private key our private key usually
copied and I yes and I asked me the
question is it possible to detect copies
out of private keys from the outside
could I find any measurement measurement
which allows me to determine if there
are copies generated on the server side
and what I did is I just measured a lot
and but I only measured the time how
long it takes to open a TLS connection
and my assumption was like that if only
one key exists and I do these
measurement over from different places
on these planet then I will see a
proportional factor which is related to
the speed of light of the diff sir this
distance between B and the key and out
of this I just covered I just covered
the following and that for example
amazon.com has only one key in one place
so you can hop around the whole world
and try to access them and measure the
time how long it takes to open the
connection and you will see that the
that is in proportion to the speed of
light which we need to transfer data
from A to B and if you look closer to
the later you will see okay it might be
in the area of Seattle but this is
pretty common but there are other sites
like google.com and Facebook the corner
and they look like that so I have for
measurement points I measure something
somewhere in the u.s. I measure
somewhere in the Europe I measure
somewhere in Japan and a lot not least
in Australia and I discover that the
keys must be within and perimeter of
2002 till May
us around my measurement points and out
of this there are no intersections I
could basically in induct and say okay
there might must be four copies of the
key at least to get this pattern working
of course every open petiole s
connection needs to make use of the
private key and to get these timings
it's only possible if you are having the
key copied over to the specific location
or you will see the higher latency
during the transfer to a central point
where the keys this resists but living
yeah and this ends up with one
interesting thing okay it's normal that
we have copies of keys out so it's not
like like my house house at my house at
home where I know okay I have one key or
three keys and in this case I definitely
know there will be copies and it's a
very common pattern to copy the private
key in Internet it's not same there are
other use cases where you need to copy
you he's also all of this I did another
assumption and say ok I and say Amazon
will have one key at least it could be
unpacked back amazon.com will have one
key at least and google.com I say ok
they will probably have hundred thousand
copies of the app private key
spread it around their network it's just
an assumption I would be it would be
very cool to hear the real numbers but I
say ok it must be bigger than hundred
thousand um and out of this I did some
some risk analyzers and say ok if I
multiply the the possibility of losing
one key with the with the existence of
one hundred thousand keys
then I will be get a value of around 10%
risk to lose the key if you have got
100,000 copies then one of them might be
loves and so the risks of losing is 10%
in if you have got hundred thousand
copies if you have got a million copies
the risk is even higher
it's 63% percent that's a lot a lot so
the risk is also increasing in that and
out of this I said okay but what can I
do to gain back trust in in this so I
know that Google might be loose lost her
turkey of course if they have got
there's a 10% chance to lose a key and
what can I do to gain back control with
it there's a lot of other problems like
scaling and so on but I could say if I
have the facility you just call it
facility where I can my private key in
in but in but will will still still be
able to use it for encryption and
signing then it might be better of
course
this device stores the key but never Lee
allows to leave the key again so if I
know that this kind of device is would
be exists then I could say okay it's not
a problem but if this device exists I
would see the Amazon timing of course
there's yeah there there might be no
copies you only have one key that's
what's going on there it's a liberal
side track but it's also important so we
have these certified authorities we have
the certifications we use for TLS that
we have so that they broadly called
public key infrastructure or pika PK
eyes and they are built to maintain the
integrity of public keys
that's the only purpose a do they never
want they never do anything or touches
the private key integrity so we have
that that's a vacuum there's nothing in
so nobody cares about the private keys
at all and but they are the the reason
why we are trusting on keys so it's
pretty easy pretty difficult and I came
to the conclusion and saying okay
they're the weakest link of the chain of
trust we have is the private key of my
communication partner that's basically
or that is the fundamental thing so if I
did not know how my partner and
communication handles his private keys I
barely could trust them which a little
bit means we cannot trust anybody this
raises the question which is there any
solution to these problem to maintain
the the private key integrity and my
honest an answer to that is I have no
clue so there is in the scale of a
worldwide organization no chance to deal
with that there are some approaches but
generally speaking on current technology
basis we have no solution to trust on
other keys if they are copied but
luckily that is a little tiny solution
that we could use to our own private
keys so every private key you have and
use on daily basis you can protect
though you can protect with the use of
smart cards so smart cards are these
devices I had before
which says okay it is only a one way
road you can put a key em but you will
never keep get a key out or better smart
cuts are also able to generate the key
within the card so it never exposed the
card the key to anyone else but you can
still use it to protecting and copying
yeah to put a you can still users for
encryption signing and so on but you
will never ever su own you will never
get your private key material but in
hand so that you could copy it the only
ability to accesses is to take the smart
cut and use it so that's pretty cool
that these kind of things exist and yeah
I'm done at this point of course I'm
lost control a little bit of time out of
these starting problems so I have to say
say thank you to my friend Ken
Grampa's Sabatini in go banter who works
in Aurora miles from now Google and the
Jas comes and you audience
[Applause]